kelly clarkson wins the voice on her
first season out but more importantly
she beat blake happy hump day people it
feels like all the reality competition
shows our crowning winners this week
last night the voice named the youngest
winner of the show ever
fifteen-year-old Brynn cartelli walks
away with $100,000 and a recording
contract but also bragging rights for
team Kelly we already know Kelly
Clarkson is the very first winner of
American Idol and now on her first
season of The Voice Kelly is also the
winning coach but she also gets a new
title thanks to a bet she made with
Blake Lee so it's Blake called you Queen
Kelly Clarkson oh girl don't think I'm
not waiting yes
oh yeah haven't checked my phone but I'm
gonna hold him to it yes the Alicia now
is so funny at the end we were like we
love Britain as well and we both
obviously she does this of course but so
does so does bringe we love Britain and
and it was one of those things we were
like regardless like a female's walking
out of here a winner and it was it was
really Elysian eyes gold just to beat
the cowboy so success how long does he
have to call you that I don't I don't I
don't know if we put a I think all next
season she's loving that she beat him
she I know right joining me now is so
Keisha lacy you covered the voice all
season long and what a fun season with
Kelly on I mean oh [ __ ] mainly because
of that whole Blake and Kelly friendly
rivalry oh listen
they brought it and for so long it was
Blake versus Adam and that whole thing
but this season listen Kelly came to win
and more importantly she really came to
beat Blake I got to witness their
constant back and forth firsthand so
hilarious now what you have to remember
here is that Kelly's husband is also
Blake's manager does your husband tell
you to go easy on Blake ready now get on
the show now now they have the same
relationship whose team is he on was he
did both no he's
[Laughter]
manager when she's on the show just
locking up wins music is in my circle
I'm sorry I funny far before you wait a
minute yeah it's weird or song that's
funny you got called out it didn't sound
like her song on Fallon that sounded
wrong we partied in Vegas go ahead and
performed it was very weak Le Guin
partied wasted just destroyed Kelly
threw up I actually literally ended up
at wheel of fortune slots throwing up in
her shirt pocket I hope and I hope for
about me as she has you and you're like
one of the realest people that I've ever
met you have a really down earth energy
go ahead we're done talking we forgot
you were here
I won't hear a new question at this
point come equation he they said say one
nice thing about Michael Sol what the
hell she's married to my manager I can't
say these things see that right there is
why I was so happy
Kelly's returning to the voice thanks
Susan oh me too along with Jennifer
Hudson but miss Clarkson is defending
her title next season I can't wait to
see what sort of trick Blake has up his
sleeve next season for her I'm so good
good TV a shameless plug so we just
interviewed voice winner Brynn today on
ET live that's up on ET space book page
and our youtube channel right now psi is
she is the cutest human ever I'm
obsessed with I love that one well thank
you cute human hey you guys it is time
to give you a preview of the hottest
movies coming up this summer for that
and more we're swapping in another
brunette beauty miss ash cross she knew
it show shoes on oh my gosh well it's
already been an amazing great summer
movie season which left me on a start
well like in May you know we've already
had Deadpool to an Avengers affinity war
they're currently in theaters they're
amazing but really kicking off the
official official season is solo a Star
Wars horse race come on first thing I'm
gonna bring up we're following the
adventures of a young Han Solo han and
chewie meeting for the first time early
adventures with Lando Calrissian at a
bunch of twists turns and I'm not
kidding you surprises you know
gave a mixed review on it overall it is
a really fun flick and a lot of people
doubted it but Alden and Donald both in
crime I did not doubt it
for the record the record yes we got ok
similar in the genre we have ant-man and
the wasp about it see you next Marvel
film and that's out July 6 ant-man is
back and he has a new antagonist ghost
who in the comics is a man but in the
movie it's played by John Hannah John
came in I'm sorry and I'm already a
little bit extremely obsessed with her
that's you know instead of bodging her
name and of course we're adding Michelle
Pfeiffer who may is playing Janet Van
Dyne who was the original block so it
doesn't get better I love that what
about the indie world oh my gosh okay so
speaking of obsessed I love to him
because I want to give you guys a little
bit of a nanny gem you know the movie
that people aren't as hyped about it but
you need two hearts beat loud' it's a
really really cute movie with a father
and daughter kind of exploring the
summer before the daughter goes to
college and it's with Nick Offerman and
Kiersey Clemons it's really sweet they
start a band together it's really
heartwarming and there's there's a lot
of original music in it of that scale
but I got to talk about the one I'm most
excited for oceans a ocean ocean but
it's finally here June 8th if the oceans
franchise is back but this time it's all
ladies and they're taking down the Met
Gala
so we're starring Sandra Bullock Cate
Blanchett and Hathaway Mindy Kaling
Sarah open up have you heard have you
heard of so many okay so we've got
double to Avengers infinity war ant-man
so it seems like there's a lot of
superheroes here's one that's not gonna
give us any fatigue cuz it's been a
decade since we are with The Incredibles
over a decade and now we're back with
Incredibles 2 whole gang is back
together
Pixar oh very exciting bunny yeah any
for didn't and then let's go all the way
to August because this is one that has
been they've already been screening it a
lot of really really great feedback
about this one it's based on the
best-selling novel
crazy rich Asians pretty funny we've
heard a lot of buzz about this one it's
not so August but oh my god okay so this
one is about a chinese-american
professor who travels to Singapore to
meet her boyfriend's family and
discovers that they are crazy rude
the movie all the antics obviously I
talked to the Lee Henry Golding and they
are so excited for this movie to be out
I'm excited I know a lot of people have
as you mentioned have praised this bill
I'm very excited also Aquafina having a
summer because she's also an oceans 8
and increases awkwafina come to daily
dunny okay want to give you love okay
are you guys
speaking of love there's so much more on
this list we have a full list of 27
movies to look like this summer
available on ET online in the theater
every weekend so true so go check it out
tomorrow sophie will be back with a
preview of the big albums dropping in
the summer so stay tuned for that I will
see you guys then thank you